il progresse à la seule lueur de leur
lampe frontale ainsi toute la nuit les
pompiers ont mené le combat contre le
feu sur les hauteurs de la grande
verrière que c'est un fait extrêmement
compliquée avec d une zone des zones
d'accès très difficile
donc le feu progresse lentement
néanmoins nous nous avons demandé un
groupe supplémentaire pour pouvoir le
stopper sur la partie basse et même
lorsque le feu semble avoir disparu
après avoir tout détruit il réapparaît
ici et là les flammes crépitent
doucement dans le langage des pompiers
on appelle cela des foyers résiduels les
hommes et femmes engagés sur le terrain
doivent donc être très attentif et
réagit rapidement bien mouillé surtout
les souches d'arbres et après j'espérais
qu'il ait pas devant élevé que ça
reparte pas pour combattre les flammes
ils seront plus d'une centaine de
pompiers de saône-et-loire épaulés par
leurs collègues de côte-d'or et il
fallait bien cela car dans l'après midi
impossible de ne pas apercevoir les
fumées elle était visible à plusieurs
kilomètres à la ronde pourtant tout
avait été tenté pour stopper voir
limiter les incendies
dès qu'il avait été découvert lorsque
nous sommes arrivés donc le feu était en
bordure de la route départementale
numéro 3 à côté de maisons d'habitation
et donc nous sommes allés en mairie
récupérer des extincteurs afin de
contenir le feu et d'éviter qu'il se
propage à une citerne de gaz et qui le
fasse des dégâts très importants à la
maison d'habitation qui jouxte donc le
départ de feu est même le château situé
en plein milieu de la forêt pu être
sauvés mais au total une trentaine
d'hectares ont été détruits c'est un
secteur très boisé avec une dominante de
résineux donc très sensibles aux départs
de feu parce que si le feu gagne
résineux et sapinière notamment alors là
à l'extension n'est pas facile à
maîtriser
finalement la pépinière a été épargnée
mais les pompiers sont encore sur place
au kazoo